okay what up guys
morning
coffee okay
oh that's kind of hot that's kind of hot
okay
if i sound a little hoarse it's because
i am
my god people were here so late last
night
but it was it wasn't really their fault
because
sometimes as a nice host of my show
i offer people pizza after not always i
can't afford pizza every time but
yesterday we had a big guest here like
he's
a good amount of subs and um i don't pay
my guests
um because
i can't afford to and be honest it's
just not
it's not not to the point like
it would even matter to them right so
when they come i try to i try to do two
things i try to one offer attractive
women on the show
if it's a bigger like dude right because
then they're gonna want to come back
right if i offer you attractive women or
two i try to make you feel like i don't
know i try to i try to be hospitable as
best i can
anyways that's so this pizza
was supposed to come like it came an
hour late we were literally waiting oh
my god
anyways that's not even why i started
this coffee talk today so this coffee
talk
i want to talk about if people ask me
about
red pill and if i think like girls
shouldn't be an only fan i really
don't even ask me like i always see
comments saying like oh you're
pushing traditional values
guys you realize i don't push anything
i don't really give advice on this
channel it's just not
i might someday
but right now it's just not it's for
entertainment
and it's more to like analyze what's
going on in the world so
i never tell girls what to do okay i
never tell them not to sleep around i
never tell them not to
go on only fans what i say is if you do
that these are the consequences
okay
so
i'm not going to tell you what to do
but what i don't like and what we see a
lot in the society
is lying to other women where they say
there's no consequences for doing that
you're beautiful in any size like that
stuff is just lying or
put the career first above all else like
i don't even really believe in like
girls getting married at like
22 23 to be honest like
because statistically like marriages
work out better
like the the longest like rates of
marriages are after the age of 25.
um but
there's pros and cons to everything and
there's still a lot of pros to having
kids and getting married in your early
20s like you're done sooner
even for guys there's you know they say
to wait till you're 35 to get the
highest quality mate
that is a pro but a con
is if you wait till you're 35 to get
married you're gonna be old as hell
raising these kids
and some guys are okay with that they're
like that's fine
but i'm gonna tell you my dad is like 50
something
how old is my dad he's like 50 something
i don't know
and
he's like get these kids out of my house
he's so tired of us
i called them the other day i was like
can i move in back in next year i miss
you guys he's like no
no get out because my youngest sister
she's she's 10 years younger than me i'm
25.
he's she's 15
and lives with my parents clearly my
dad's like 50 something like
it's just the way i look at life is
everything has a cost so
you know girls you wait longer to get
married you might not get as quality of
a guy because you're not as good looking
that's cost
way too long to get married you might
not be able to have so many kids
what's the cost
so
everything in life has a cost
and
i just like to be
aware like i just like to tell people
what the cost is instead of lying to
them
but
i have a little bit more i think nuance
than a lot of the man of sphere does
because
i just feel like people are different
and people have different like
personality traits that make them
like i don't think my mom ever could
have been stay a stay-at-home like wife
like i don't know she likes working
she's always liked working
and
there's pros and cons of having my mom
home or not home
so i don't know if that makes sense
like
it was kind of cool to like grow up
seeing my mom working all the time like
that's part of the reason i think i work
really hard
but the con was we also grew up with
nannies but we there's 10 of us like
the menosphere will be like
okay this is the crazy thing i hate the
manosphere sometimes because they'll try
to dog on my family for having nannies
growing up
and i'm like y'all my parents produced
10 good
functioning members of society okay
every kid older than me makes six
figures i ruined the trend okay in the
family
sorry dad
sorry mom
um but like seriously every kid like all
my brothers are engineers
and honestly like it was from like
watching
the our parents like they're just really
hard workers
so i don't know i don't
i don't believe everything's black and
white and we had that show guest come on
and say that i just believe in being
honest that there are consequences and i
say
that growing up in a one percent family
has its perks i have no college debt
i get to pursue something i'm interested
in
a lot of people don't get to do that huh
but
the con was growing up i didn't really
know my dad
great relationship now but everything
comes at a cost y'all
and i just think we should be honest
with people about the costs that's my
final thoughts
drink your coffee
or don't i think it stains your teeth
yeah maybe don't if you're not addicted
but i'm addicted so all right i'll talk
to you later bye